bonsoir si on s
arrêtez pas drôle mba ça te dirait de
juin je
porte à déverrouiller
de verrouiller
déverrouiller
[Musique]
allo ça recommence on en est déjà à
trois attaques tu as une arme tu parles
à sydney prescott bien sûr que j'ai une
arme
j'ai l'impression que cette fois c'est
différent
samantha je suis je sais qui vous êtes
je suis passé par là encore et encore ce
sera ta vie à partir de maintenant parce
que qui que ce soit il va pas te lâcher
tu es prête pour ça jamais
il y à certaines règles pour survivre
il s'en est pris uniquement à des gens
liés au premier tueur
je sais pas tu es liens il a avec notre
passé
mais on se retrouve tous ici
et je dormirai pas tant qu'il sera pas
mort
bonsoir sydney
c'est un honneur